carlos tercero entregó sus primeras
palabras oficiales como monarca del
reino unido- y la mancomunidad de las
naciones el nuevo rey pronunció un breve
discurso de menos de cinco minutos en el
cual juró mantenerse en el cargo hasta
el día de su muerte y lamentó la partida
de su madre la reina isabel segunda a
quien rindió un homenaje
misma emerson es mi deber más doloroso
anunciarles la muerte de mi amada madre
la reina se cuán profundamente ustedes
lo lamentan la nación entera entones y
creo que puedo decir que el mundo entero
se solidariza conmigo en la gran pérdida
que todos hemos tenido en el repro
pueblos tribus software el nuevo
soberano de 73 años dio sus palabras
ante los miembros del consejo de
adhesión figuras públicas y políticos
como los ex primeros ministros
británicos tony blair y gordon brown
david cameron divisa male boris johnson
y la recién posesionada listos el rey
firmó el juramento que pronunció ante el
consejo y además nombró al príncipe
william como nuevo príncipe de gales y
camila parker como reina consorte a
quien agradeció por su apoyo y nobles a
todo esto me siento profundamente
alentado por el apoyo constante de mi
amada esposa y malvela virtual
y ordenó que el día del funeral de la
reina será festivo el cual está planeado
para el 19 de septiembre a las 11 de la
mañana siguiendo el protocolo de the
london bridge establecido por la misma
reina en la década de los sesentas la
ceremonia privada finalizó con la
proclamación de un funcionario real en
el cual informó al público desde un
balcón del palacio de saint james en
londres que el rey carlos tercero es un
nuevo soberano convirtiéndose en la
primera confirmación oficial entretanto
se escuchaban los saludos con armas
resonando en el hyde park en la torre de
londres
y así su majestad concluye los asuntos
de hoy para el consejo